it's just a coincidence that many Elites
in Hollywood and big Tech are also some
of the harshest critics of the sound of
Freedom movie does Michael think it's a
coincidence I'm just thinking about it
for a second
don't give me the answer
it's cheating it's cheating
[Music]
I don't usually get Star Struck I've met
plenty of famous people but it is very
rare to meet one of the Great American
Heroes it's very rare to meet one of the
greatest living actors and it is rarer
to meet them both at the exact same time
but that is what we are doing on today's
episode of yes or no where I am joined
by the greats Jim Caviezel and Tim
Ballard now before we get to this game
and before you get to see the guys
you gotta head on over to dailywire.com
shop where you can get your very own
copy of the yes or no game Jim Caviezel
and Tim Ballard are not included in the
pack but you will get lots of cards and
game pieces you can play with up to nine
people figure out how well you know your
friends and family that is dailywire.com
shop gentlemen
thank you for coming on the show well as
impressed as you are my family knows
that this idiot is terrible at these
board games so I don't know what we're
doing I'm glad so the basic idea of it
is we're each going to take I'll take a
card I'll read The Prompt then later on
you'll take a card and when you read The
Prompt okay we're gonna guess how the
other person would answer so if I read
whatever the prompt is I say okay I
think Jim says yes and I move your drink
to yes okay and then however you think
I'll answer you move my drink to
wherever that is and we figure out who's
right somehow people are rewarded points
and then we're going to switch you out
for you Tim but let's begin Jim with you
and let's see how bad we are turning
money down because of the whole game
okay all right
it's a good conversation starter but in
reality getting struck by lightning is
really not as bad as it sounds uh yes
the answer yes would be it's not so bad
the answer no would be it's pretty bad
how would I think that Jim Caviezel
would answer this question I would say
Jim Caviezel answers
that it's pretty bad to get struck by
lightning
how now you move my game piece
so I got to be honest right yes honest
with how you think I would answer the
question I think that you need to tell
me if you think that I think that it is
good or bad to be struck by life
I don't even know what that answer means
so yes I'm going to say that it's not
that that it's not that bad to get
struck by lightning
oh no no okay there we go I'm dyslexic
okay mysters are basically illiterate so
don't worry about it so so we answered
the same
um I don't have any experience being
struck by lightning okay
he does obviously I do
okay
so I I think that you would think
that it hurts pretty bad and you would
be right yeah so I answered that correct
you it did answer it first flipped it
around it's a lot okay what does it feel
like
ah it's it's uh
you're serious right are you uh it's
it's hard
I got lit up like a Christmas tree pal
so this was during the filming of the
passion yes I did
what were you do were you on like were
you on the cross were you no no I was on
um this is the last shot of the movie I
went up uh the hillside there's about
300 people in location uh you know it
was The Sermon on the Mount
I got to the top
and on the fifth take uh there was a I
it was really blowing really hard and it
looked like the clouds were so low you
could reach up and touch them and so
that felt like this is something really
wrong here and the ground felt like
it was reverberating or something and
then
on the fifth take about three seconds
before I got hit I looked down and I saw
two people and their eyes were watering
because it felt like and the thing is
you you're in like an eye of a storm the
wind is blowing you can't hear it
and this feel just like pulls your hair
up and came down and it was uh like an
implosion of your head and an explosion
of your head but the first thing I felt
was like it just
an implosion I shot out my body I saw my
back and I came back and then Yama
colini comes over
I've never said this publicly so he
comes over and he says are you okay and
he's gotta now at this point he had a
um a lightning rod he essentially had a
umbrella and his I saw his hand blow up
I went down
they took me out and then in 2000 and I
was on lots of medication from 2000 and
full two
till 2009 when I had my first heart
surgery by Dr Patrick Wall in Stanford
and then my second major heart surgery
was Dr Griffin and Dr gillenoff Who
Saved My Life at Cleveland Clinic
this is then that was from it's all from
that yeah and then they completely cured
me and I've never had a any problem
since but it was for for those you know
12 years tough so I had heard I'd heard
the stories you know that you were
struck by lightning on the set but I
thought it was just a like little zap oh
you know ouch that hurts I didn't you're
talking years yeah
yeah whoa so I I'd have you know when I
get up for I was always on you know uh
blood thinners coumadin and stuff to
keep the heart corrected from you know
you know and the 2009 they seemed to fix
it and then it just all got worse in 14
so but you know still here you're still
here just you know if of any kind of
spiritual warfare really kicking in I
know both of you gentlemen are quite
aware of that phenomenon yeah
final shot of The Passion of the Christ
would probably be a place where those
sorts of things come together in the
providential scope yeah
wow the line in the scriptures when
Jesus said I saw Satan come down like
lightning
and I knew we were going to have a huge
hit from that point
it was like calling an airstrike in on
yourself and I said well you know
there's a lot of people that are going
to have
come into Jesus moment and millions did
and and millions more will keep coming
so it's a it's a annuity of the highest
level
um you know when I die they'll just keep
coming
um and uh
and you know it's it it is a cross but
um when Mel and I do the resurrection
well that that one is going to be a game
changer like nobody can imagine and
those two films will be the biggest
films in the history of the world right
now go to hallow.com Knowles pretty
clear that the libs have given up
whatever morals and Common Sense they
ever had there is no better time to
build a daily habit of prayer and
meditation building a habit of prayer
can help you cultivate an attitude of
gratitude focusing on what you are
thankful for in increased positive
emotions and improve overall well-being
hallow is the number one Christian
Prayer app in the United States it is
helping a lot of people to maintain a
daily prayer routine and it can help you
too download the app for free at
hallow.com Knowles you can set prayer
reminders and track your progress along
the way not sure where to start check
out father Mike schmitz's Bible in a
year podcast available on the Hallow app
it's my favorite podcast for brief daily
Bible readings and Reflections or prey
alongside Mark Wahlberg pray alongside
Jim Caviezel and even some world-class
athletes with Halo you can customize a
personal prayer plan that works for you
listen wherever you are with
downloadable offline sessions using Halo
to connect with others who share your
beliefs and values can provide a sense
of belonging support Foster a sense of
community right now download hello.com
Knowles get an exclusive three months
for free three months free at hallow.com
so now you
you read
your question there's no way I'm going
to have an answer nearly as good as that
one but you read this question and we do
it again
I said he's blind I'm his interpreter
it's just the coincidence that many
Elites in Hollywood and big Tech are
also some of the harshest critics of the
sound of Freedom movie oh wow that's
that's a loaded question for you go for
it go
do they say it's just a coincidence it's
just a coincidence yeah okay so I'll
answer as I think
Jim and Tim in this case would answer
are you gonna answer this one no you're
you gotta you got to move my my class to
how you think I would answer this does
Michael think it's a coincidence
I'm just thinking about it for a second
I don't think
don't give me the answer
it's cheating it's cheating
of course
correct I assume I guessed correctly uh
for you as well Jim
yes
that's correct
I don't really believe in coincidences
neither do I
now usually the rule is uh you drink
when you get a question wrong but I feel
we're going to be getting too many
rights so I'm just gonna I'm gonna say I
don't have to drink I think I get to
drink oh my gosh that's actual I thought
that was like water no that's a
delicious Martini you can offer you uh
you know if listen it's it's just here
if you want to sit you gentlemen are
being much more responsible for an
afternoon you got the Mormon over here
of course you put the Catholic in here
wait a decision
this Gray Goose that is it's gin it's uh
Boodles oh
great kind of esoteric gin but you know
made to our specification by the
producer team okay so now I go
Jim's still focused on well no because
we'll put that card he has something to
say about this yeah yeah
um
sound of Freedom was tied up for five
years bro why
well we had we had um Fox and then
Disney bought it and
I'll tell you um
when I did The Count of Monte Cristo
um
they I agreed to do the movie and then
when we came to Ireland they re
completely rewrote the script and they
had no say in doing that because of my
in my contract said on two parts one the
director Kevin Reynolds that I that I'm
a part of the process and you can't
rewrite my stuff without my say so they
rewrote it
and the part in the movie that was taken
out was when they rewrote it was they
removed all of God out of the movie
and um so it wasn't God will give me
Justice have you by chance I love the
movie yeah I love the movie
I mean and so the Disney executive that
was there was you know this is I said
why was that taken out of the movie and
he says so oh like are you one of those
I said one of those what one of those
who rewrite Alexander Demar that
rewrites
um Shakespeare because that's exactly
what you did you got to put that back in
I don't know if it was like when the
count is in the OR Edmund is in the
prison it was like
um some humanism you know find it in
yourself or whatever whatever it was new
age nonsense whatever but the but you
know he's Americans who are one nation
under God we believe that and um
um many of us would die for it and I
certainly wouldn't
I gave my career
believing that I was so profoundly moved
by The Ten Commandments by Charlton
Heston I was so profoundly moved by
Jimmy Stewart and It's a Wonderful Life
when he's in the bar and he says you
know God if you're out there please help
me because I've been there
now here I have an opportunity to
express that in this film it has to be
there and and um and then Charlton
Heston of course had been her in 1959 so
the industry has gone away yeah way way
way to a point where and us I'll have
this conversation with any of them
why do you think your films are not
producing you do not speak for the
people any longer right and sound of
Freedom does
it it sound of freedom is from your
heart yeah sound of freedom is something
that
um
Burns inside you and you can't put it
out you see and when I came back and I
heard those children screaming I my
first part was like I gotta find a place
in this movie where maybe I can take the
eye and and do something to where I take
you to the edge I can't show you what's
happening to this little girl with this
man but I can take you into my Iris and
it takes you to the edge of your seats
Hitchcock yeah and then you get to
understand what burns in this man's
heart every day and it's a hard life
it's a big cross but he it's a purpose
and so when I was a young man and I was
going to movies
and I felt like you know God are you out
there when I was at a lowest point in my
life that I screamed out at 14 you know
I don't want to live anymore that's five
times worse now and I go and talk to
those kids yeah
and I say as bad as it seems I want to
tell you my story and I tell them and I
said had I taken my own life
can you imagine our loving God
as a 14 year old and said look what I
was look what I was going to do for you
look you were going to play my son
you know so this is a game of life
but it's a profound
profound game that we're in right now
and it's all about what we do for him
because at the end is the only thing
that matters and you can't take and your
Rolex says what's going on oh Jesus died
so Jim Caviezel his Rolex gets to go to
heaven this is junk in heaven not that
I'm going to give it to you yeah
but you know but listen if the spirit
does move your gym and you want to get
rid of it just let me I'm right here so
it's okay all right no it's it you know
on the question is it a just a
coincidence that the powers and the
principalities and the spiritual witness
in high places of this world
always wants to push God out of all of
it and then you refuse to do it and it's
no I mean we're talking about some of
your movies now
your movies are all excellent and
they're and they're all excellent they
all resonate with people in a way that
other movies also with big actors and
big scripts and in the way that they
don't and why is that
there's there's something in your movies
that are not in the movies offered by
the principalities and the powers
to which point currently the CIA does
more harm than good
we got any open windows in the studio
right now I want to answer this question
what are you doing this up
currently the CIA does more harm than
good uh
now you you're thinking what I'm
thinking right that's what that was yeah
okay now I just want to go over this
again so that's what you think I'd say
that's what I thought oh I got it all I
gotta think what you say
should do we need to verbally confirm
that we are obviously correct and our
guess is here can we kind of like let
this
lie you know
I you know what I think I believe that
if they think you're afraid then you're
in trouble hmm
I I look at it this way I unlike you I
know I'm gonna die someday
I've got it I've got at least two
centuries here how long am I gonna die
man you say well you know I've seen a
lot of old people die in nursing homes
pretty in the worst way you know why
they're alone yeah because their
families abandon them you know why they
abandon them they're afraid of the cross
hmm I'm afraid
and guess what the person that's
suffering the most
they don't even see that pain I didn't
care they just worry about themselves
whenever we get in a position where
we're worried about our own skin we're
in trouble
and Jesus talks about
fear not the people that can kill you
your flesh it's the second one
that's the one that you got to be
concerned about the most so we're all
getting out of this dead right right so
I'm gonna hear the uh Body and Soul
going sick henna that's the bigger yeah
that's why you gotta have a nice drink
baby
let me get Christopher walking on this
show today this is a big win I love this
at the end of the show I gotta have a
bite of that Olive
not only drinks but appetizers too uh
Europe
um
in the sound of Freedom the only part of
Jim caviezel's performance that could
have been improved was his lack of
this is lack of muscle tone why do I
have to read this right now to better
reflect the person he was playing many
people have
so I know I gotta answer is there a gym
would answer here
you gotta answer
yes because
you know now listen not everybody you
know can be you know uh
300 muscle like a discovery but yes
because you know that every other aspect
of the performance
perfect how's that yeah and so I took
that insult from The Producers turned it
into a compliment turned it right on
yeah like that and it's sincere company
and and in all honesty I talked to him
about this I said Jim can you do a
steroid something
when I was younger I was prettier
[Laughter]
you know I was a big man me I have not
that you know what basketball I was
working out with this guy and he had
huge you know beautiful legs and
everything big strong guy and he put on
the weight on the squat rack and I said
that's all you're going to put on for me
because that's I mean
go ahead rack him up and I put this guy
right into the ground so really I don't
look as pretty as well
but uh strength is is a good is is is
there I'm not I'm not trying to go up
against you in a gym I'm not
ever
dull the pain okay the reason
that this gets to the point of the movie
the reason the exploitation of children
is so pervasive while also actively
ignored is that it's satanic and
spiritual in nature
yeah I'll just leave the cup right there
I'm sorry what was the statement again
the reason the exploitation of children
is so pervasive while also actively
ignored is that it is satanic and
spiritual
yeah it is way too easy yeah of course
it's been true since the dawn of time
amen
I think that I'll drink to that you can
drink today yeah I'll have a sip after
you episode uh you're up all right just
so you know Jim you're supposed to be
drinking out of your cup yeah that one's
not as I think you're the first guest
ever in the Michael Miller show that's
drinking out of his cup I actually kind
of like it it's a nice it's a it's a big
Martini we'll get a refill we'll let you
get up here did you put did you put
vodka in the coffee
all right chat GPT is basically the beta
version of Samaritan from Person of
Interest
I don't know what's happening well I'll
tell you a person of interest is the TV
show
what's chat jbt oh it's you know you you
it's like AI they can like put like in
China with the yeah come on if you put
an idea and they write it for you yeah
yeah
well I think I just got the answer then
yeah I think I'm gonna defer to the star
of Person of Interest
you know it's interesting when we were
working on that show um Jonah Norman
came over to man
um
he uh introduced you to my friend and
comes over and I said ah
I and I look familiar and I said hey
this guy is an actor I know I know I
know I've seen I'm trying to remember
what film he's in and and so I said um I
can't I'm so nice to me I know you've
done some great films and everything or
I I I'm so sorry I just can't place you
and it's a TV show or something that
I've seen yet he was my name is Elon
Musk
and Elon was embarrassed for me but what
show were you on Elon yeah he was on for
16 minutes the night before yeah by the
way did you see
Elon Musk tweeted about sound of Freedom
did he a week ago yeah amazing and he
said he's going to provide Twitter is
going to be a free platform for Center
freedom I think mid July he's going to
open it up for free and you know
distribute it worldwide I was whatever
reticence or skepticism I had had early
on of Elon yeah Elon gets it Elon gets
it you know he
all the other big Tech guys shutting
everything down but Elon Elon gets it
all right I'm up the pyramid the Great
Pyramid of Giza was built by primitive
Egyptians who used wet sand to move 2.3
million perfectly cut blocks averaging
2.3 tons each from quarries up to 500
miles away in a span of about 20 years
in other words the official scientistic
story of the Great Pyramid of Giza yes
the whole story
well I thought that was part okay so
isn't there a mystery about the wonders
of the world yeah I think so
which means and now I got your see now
this is the thing
Jim kind of tips his hand you know a
little bit a little bit on the but yeah
I think there's a little bit more to the
story than just uh my brain works like
it puts a square peg into a circular
hole we I figure out the but the SAT not
very good it's just not gonna work all
right you're up
all right
I don't have my glasses here all right
in general it's more difficult to be a
practicing Christian in Hollywood than
it is to make it in Hollywood
to be a practicing Christian edit well
okay oh there's some ambiguity I'll just
answer how I how I interpret the
question and then
give my thoughts
yes yes because I'm not just
interpreting that as you make it in
Hollywood and then you're a practicing
Christian I mean just to be a Christian
now living in Hollywood at any level
anywhere on the totem pole or in the
industry it is such a seductive place
and there is so much titillation
everywhere I mean we call it Gamora by
the Sea yeah that it is
to keep your faith yeah
in that at any level yes can be very
difficult
so I'm going to quote Mel Gibson on this
Jim
from his experience he says it's a lot
easier
not to eat from the apple tree if you're
not standing in front of it
you got to keep moving I need faith is
is it what it it it's that way but you
got to every morning I got up
at 5 30.
when I was trying to make it
and I was in Mass at 6 30 in the morning
that's part of it you have to have you
have to work on the spirit the spirit is
going to move the mental and the
physical
most actors just do the mental and
physical and then the other other ones
if they have a spiritual thing it allows
them to do whatever they want right
right so ours has got ten commandments
there's rules and they're there to
protect you
um to unto others as you want them to do
unto you so my mindset is always how
would that feel if someone did that to
you you know and
um and at the end of the day if you're
not going to be happy after you commit
that
sin it is sin and you have to Define it
because then you don't have rules yeah
and
you're you're not going to be yeah it's
success you'll never enjoy
because you have to have
one of the gifts of the holy spirit is
gratitude
and appreciation right Jesus talks about
the salt
what it's worth
as soon as you lose the Holy Spirit you
will not be grateful and and you will
not be appreciative someone could give
you a Ferrari three days she'll be like
yeah you know and this more junk I got
to take care of you know it was a
Hollywood actor just wrote A Memoir this
is a guy who won't say his name not to
detract but he it's all public anyway I
guess big sitcom star had every
everything this guy ever wanted he got
every hot girl every dollar he ever
wanted every bit of Fame he ever wanted
and the whole time he was miserable and
because of that because there was no
sense of what it was for so it was just
you know it was as Sean Bernard Shaw
said the hell is the place where you
have nothing to do but amuse yourself
yes
you know um along the way
in this business you're going to have
war injuries okay yeah when you're
younger you get up you train you you
know have a great physical it's easy to
stay in shape in those days and then
eventually
and the passion or in gij and I severed
my left PEC so then I lost my shoulder
and I had to put the shoulder back in
and it ripped out again and and then
lower back toward you know pop to the
disc so as the time goes on and the
business though how you your physique
and everything changes it starts to it
wasn't the way you used to have it and
the bicep is ripped the ankles got a
plate in it I've got it you know Steel
in my leg and all that
but I keep fighting back I keep my scars
I've earned them you know and um and so
the the the body it doesn't matter it it
you know is at some point you have
nothing if what's inside here is corrupt
even if your body's perfect
and this is all that matters and then
from this it
and I just have to work through all of
the things it's it's humility Mother
Teresa would she say
to become humble you have to experience
humiliation
so we're not we don't usually look
forward to it but it can be very but
it's a weapon against the devil though
yeah yeah you know yeah
I'm not the best I was but I'm still
pretty good
and someday you'll get a new body anyway
you get a glorified body anyway yeah
amen okay so here we go last question
for you and then we go to Tim sure in
America today the difference between
most conspiracy theories and facts
is about six to nine months
leaving your cup there leaving your cup
there for the whole game
difference between a conspiracy theory
and effect six to nine months
if my answer were no it's only because
I'd say it's three to six months
I think it's yeah
let me tell you what I think yeah okay I
think it used to be that it's way less
than it is
a month now so I I refresh my Twitter
feed it's our it's there you're right
okay I gotta drink for that then I I
technically I got it wrong
last question for me yeah
they will be pushed by progressives will
likely be for minor detected persons
rights
over here
the next cause
you know I don't I never want to be
hyperbolic about it but I'm going to put
that on a well for what what is Jim
gonna say I'm gonna
I'm gonna say yes
and then I I think yours is
another trick
I'm gonna have to move this one yes
because look I don't want to be
hyperbolic about it I don't want to you
know jump straight to these guys are
going to normalize pedophilia it is
already happening that's my answer it
said it's going to happen the answer is
it's not the next one it's the current
one it's already happening okay you know
what if you look in California right now
it's already it's already happened it's
already happened I gotta drink them I
get to drink
let me give you some mercy thank you
very appreciate the moral and liquid
support
Jim I think you may have beaten me on
that but now we swap you out for Tim
all right Tim
here we go all right let me get my
Mormon Coke over here
I'm gonna have to keep passing my
Martini to Jim across the side dealing
with the powers of Hollywood is similar
to dealing with cartels in other
countries
it is huh absolutely I don't I only have
experience with one of those things so I
do with both because you have both yeah
so after we did the big operation this
depicted and sound of Freedom it says
October 11 2014 the largest rescue
operation probably recorded in history
is depicted in the film in Colombia and
CBS News played at Scott Pelley did a
story on it and Hollywood started
reaching out to me which unexpectedly
like hey this sounds like a movie and
and my wife and I were looking at each
other like what is going on because
we're in business because of these guys
yeah I mean these guys are creating the
content that creates this that creates
the sex addiction that creates the
demand which is why this is even
happening yeah you gotta want to have
sex with kids or even even adults who
were once abused as children you have to
want that first it has to be a demand
for that and some fuel for that fire
which is coming out of porn in Hollywood
absolutely this this is why it exists
this is why 85 000 children
unaccompanied showed up in the last two
years and were let into the country into
the biggest child sex Market in the
world people don't realize the United
States we're the number one consumers of
child sex material
we're in the top three destination
countries so it's I call it the economy
of of pedophilia so these 85 000 kids
were they they're they're being I'm
telling you a lot of them are being
abused and so it was hard for me when
Hollywood was preaching out because I'm
like the irony of it that's why when
they came to me these producers seemed
different I said he has to play me he's
the only person in Hollywood I will let
play me yeah because he loves Jesus and
and that we can fight the spiritual
warfare and still tell a story so that's
why yeah absolutely you're the only
business where you we were just talking
about this the other day
uh if you're a pedophile and you fail
you're going to go up
failing upward
and the other thing I want to say
Michael I was I was I was like I was
with speaker McCarthy last week we were
both wearing several others and they
were saying what can we do about this
border thing all these kids and I said
you got to attach it to the whole
movement yeah like you can't just say
you can't just isolate it to one thing
this whole minor attractive person's
thing the whole sexualizing of children
giving them pornography in the name of
sex education yeah at five years old
giving them 13 year olds consent to
gender mutilate is also giving them
consent to have sex with 50 year olds
you can't just you can't take it away
it's you got to combine it all and
understand that there's spiritual
warfare and children for the first time
in the history of America or at the
crosshairs yeah once you see now you can
make an argument right because it's the
same problem if you're saying a child
can consent to a permanent sexual change
based on a sexual desire how can you
then argue that a much older minor can't
consent to a one-night stand it's not
possible can't you've you've limited God
science the very virtues That Built This
Nation you've eliminated also Mom and
Dad you're getting social media hits and
you're getting Awards but when your kid
comes to you and says I want to have sex
with a 50 year old pedophile you have
You've Lost Your arguments you've sold
them to the you've sold them away right
to for popularity and this is the end of
our Republic yeah hey I have a question
for you someone asked me to ask you this
is the right time to do this
it's the same part it's the same part of
it but I think um does does pornography
lead to more pedophiles absolutely it
does oh I don't believe you what do you
know I'm a fact checkered
degree at fact checking because this is
the reason because pornography has the
same chemical reaction of the brain as
drugs so you you do marijuana so much
the chemical the dopamine endorphin hit
yeah wears down like anything else so
then you have to go to the crack cocaine
well in the porn industry you're going
to adult legal porn the same thing
happens they they want the dopamine it's
it's wearing out they got to go to
something more
and that's when they get into kids wow
that's why there's two million children
currently in the commercial sex trade
because of the porn industry and
Hollywood is feeling it so this is more
than just trafficking we've to do other
things in order to get rid of it because
we'll talk to demand which is educating
the youth and the dangers of pornography
you're up all right
[Music]
Jim caviso looked better as a blonde
uh okay will you answer for me
oh you got that wrong Tim I think the
man you naturally darker features I
think are well
maybe that was a little arrogant I mean
but I guess
I'll say I'll say this when when I told
the producers that I wanted Jim to play
me they said no they said yeah there's
no better actor but at the end of the
film there's a little cool thing where
they take real footage from the actual
we filmed the real operation yeah so
there's this cool transitional kind of
cool like into the real footage and they
said I should say I realized I haven't
quite said this yet the movie is
excellent I mean the movie is just the
acting is superb of course let's tell
them yeah I the movie is it's just no
it's superb and it's just shot
beautifully and you're handling a very
difficult subject with such delicacy in
a way that is so you just you know you
can't look away I mean you're just
watching these scenes and it's just it's
a phenomenal a lot of times I hate to
Hate to tell on conservative media a lot
of times we hawk movies that aren't that
good and because you know we like the
cause and we like the mission this movie
is just superb in every way yeah the
storytellers here on Alejandro
Monteverde Jim and the others
um but that was their one hang up is
when we the transition into the real
footage of your hair you guys are I mean
this is hard looking handsome this is
short and stocky and gringo-ish whatever
and and they couldn't reconcile it and I
said I don't care because he loved Jesus
and I can't have someone who doesn't so
that's why I probably went to hoping it
was a yes just because I think they did
a decent job they did okay it wasn't I
mean we look nothing like each other but
in the film it's it's okay I'll tell you
until until it occurred to me in this in
this question it didn't even occur to me
the the the the hair color thing or like
any it didn't even I don't know maybe
it's just because the the character well
it wishes your life the character is so
engrossing it doesn't even strike you
that people look different he has a
childlike quality that is
um like David when Goliath was insulting
his God and it didn't matter if he lived
it's just that you can't insult my God
like that and I feel the same way
and so when Jesus came I wanted to show
the world that I loved them
and I wanted the world to know that we
got to start telling God we love him
can I add that add something to that so
this is a really cool story this is
maybe my most
my favorite Story the behind the scenes
of sound of freedom and I don't even
know if you know this but
um there's one scripture that I go to if
I'm going into the dark I'm scared
people you watch the film you think I'm
brave I'm not I'm as scared as anybody
but I'm scared before and I'm freaking
out I can't watch the movie yeah but um
I'm not scared during it hmm I'm not
scared while I'm there it's like there's
a calm and the reason and there's one
scripture I just repeat over and over in
my head when I'm going into Dark Places
and it's the one time in the scripture
where Jesus
gets mafioso in his wording and it's
Jesus so it's okay it's not flipping
temples the table's the temple though he
says something that I think we just kind
of go we kind of blush by it and I'll
think about it
think about what he says he says it's
better that a millstone be wrapped
around your neck and you thrown to the
Bottom of the Sea that's that's like
cement shoes kind of stuff right then
that you should hurt one of these
children so you you actually say that
and you because that's a lot it's in the
movie you say it when you're talking but
he ad-libbed it really so he that was
not in the script and I didn't tell him
that that's my go-to so that's my
favorite scene that coffee shop yeah and
that's a real scene it's a coffee shop
that book I have the real book you know
and and Jim pulls that line out of his
you know ear but he pulls that line out
and it's really complex and creative how
he does it yeah yeah because even the
pedophile is like even the actors are
seamless he's like what are you doing
like what does that mean and and I'm
just like oh my gosh I'm sobbing and
listening to him do this he's like he
has no idea that's why I do everything I
do because I can go into Dark Places
because Jesus made us made it clear
where he stands
he is so passionate about children not
being abused that he's telling you a
warning that's that sounds like the
mafia
I love it Jesus did that
um many times and obviously the big
Grand Ballroom was the temple when he
threw them
threw them out for what they did to his
father you know and that he makes us
known to us that it's okay to defend our
God and when and you see what's
happening in the culture grooming our
children that is not going to happen
anymore
and don't worry about your career don't
worry about your life it's the second
one
the second one to gehenna and
people you know
you know you have
years ago you had
all truth no Grace so you can go
straight you know Screw Up you go
straight down fire and brimstone but
then in our time growing up it's all
Grace and no truth sleep with Susie on
Friday Catherine on Saturday go to
church on Sunday and the blood wash is
all everybody gets in
sentimental you have to have
both truth and Grace
so the devil it goes you want this I can
make it you want this no it's both so
you got to take we have to take a movie
yet soon I just felt like
an extraordinary
thing of events of Us coming together
and and them trying to keep this film
from seeing light of day but boy they're
in trouble now you know because this
thing is going to be a daisy cutter what
sold the movie you can still get your
tickets right now today Saturday you can
still get your tickets for the movie but
the movies are correct but we're dying
for theaters the movie's already sold
like a bazillion tickets right but we
we're we are struggling with theaters
because the studios control those you
know they they're the big bosses they're
the big Dons here and but what happened
on the passion same kind of thing but we
the people we're calling day and night
and the Distributors you know a lot of
them are Christian
and they're like uh look it's business
you know and if your film is not good
enough it's fair game we're going up
against Disney the Indiana Jones that's
right who used to own the film so
there's some
cool Dynamics going on right and then
right after us we're in the midweek and
then we go right into
um Tom Cruise's movie but we're
outselling Indiana Jones by 25 in the
theaters where we're competing wow
that's why Angel Studios going to this
theater and saying guys if you all do it
together they can't they can't hurt you
bump
some Indiana Jones right give us some
more screens because we're selling out
and that and the problem is is that
you're going to go oh you know wait
until the day
well you'll go there on the day and
you'll want to see the film it's sold
out so you give your money to Disney so
you give your money to the industry they
know yeah they have you and I let you
know when they say well it's just
business I think that's what the invited
guests to the wedding Feast said oh I've
got the business I got business I can't
go that's right uh you know you're going
to regret that decision gentlemen I
could stay here truly all day and
especially because we have extra gin in
the but uh we've got to get you out of
here you're on a very tight schedule
you're on a whirlwind tour and so we're
gonna close it on this question
better be a good one
it's a good that's a good question not
actually
we'll reset the glasses
Epstein killed himself
doj Watchdog just came out he they
assured us Epstein committed suicide
it's just an accident they just did and
the cameras went off and it oops
and Maxwell got convicted without any of
the end users being identified which is
impossible yeah but yeah there's no
transaction unless there's a receiver in
the transaction oh that's a that's an
interesting fact you're right there if
in order for her to be convicted for
something there must have been you have
to show a transaction two parties but
one party disappeared never revealed
and then his association with with the
intelligence apparatus of the country
that's been confirmed do you mean how
the labor secretary nominee actually
said who is U.S attorney at the time
Prosecuting Epstein said that he learned
that that he had to lay off Epstein
because he belonged to intelligence
exactly how what a what a strange
coincidence yeah
it's crazy it's crazy game but I have
one thing to say about uh I gotta have
some more cowbell babe we'll get it
after this movie comes out we'll all be
wearing gold diapers man you know that's
magical I gotta tell you everybody does
it Christopher Walken yeah that's a
shockingly good question that is a spot
on Coss give you the best babe
um
Joy o'meal
I gotta say one more thing though one
one thing yeah when we screen this
in Las Vegas
1500 people five screenings
and during one section of sound of
freedom
they were all talking
and I thought that's unusual but not
just once same place same time five
different times and I I it was a blind
spot
after the end of the five screenings got
up talked to all of them I said why were
you guys talking during this one
particular part
sound of Freedom that you got to say
that you gotta see
and they um
they they all screamed out Epstein
Island
right and I did I had that on watching
the movie and which if you realize it it
ain't the only sex Island out there
so
I I had that so I'm watching the
screener and there's a not spoiler alert
there's a scene takes place on an island
and
it was the first thought I had was oh
yeah it's a little Saint James or just
one of perhaps the many little Saint
James out there a lot of uh really
important stories that you are living
that you are telling the movie guys is
just simply excellent and
it would be enough that it's important
it would be enough that it's reflecting
this unbelievable work
but it's just excellent and people need
to get their tickets if they still can I
think they're still on sale we'll see if
it's sold out so head on over tickets
they're pushing it I mean they're
pushing how big they want to make this
angel.com angel.com
they didn't do Tim they didn't yeah
that's fine look it's fine it's fine one
letter off yeah one letter off uh Jim
thank you wait wait before we leave can
I do one more no one question absolutely
not I got a question all right let's go
I got I I've been kind of watching I
spent most of the time over here
watching just observing this game and I
have one question
is this the first time that one of your
guests
swaps saliva with you by taking part by
partaking of the same cup even though he
was supposed to partake of his own cup
it's alcohol no no so I I just have to
know the answer to this because this
that has never once happened on this
show this is the first time he who
drinks from the cup I drink let me tell
you I I actually had the thought and uh
but if you I feel like I've got
permission Jim says it's not the Holy
Grail
I actually do you know this is a true
then we'll then I'll let you go but this
this was a story that I mentioned to Jim
a little bit earlier a priest friend of
mine very close priest friend of mine uh
Jim was once staying at his rectory in
in New York and the pope was in town and
uh this is like William F Buckley
version of a Catholic priest yes he's a
very wonderful wonderful man and uh but
he he said I have I'm obligated to go
see the pope right now but I'm I'm
really upset by this fact and I think
it's ridiculous because I have Jesus
Christ himself in my rectory and I
thought that was a a great observation
and an honor Jim that uh you and I could
share this martini and Tim that you and
I if I wasn't born
thank you gentlemen both thank you for
the great movie and uh I look forward to
seeing it in theaters if I can get a
ticket we'll get you one
thanks Mike we'll pay it forward for you
foreign